MATT GAUNT: You must have
used Dreamweaver, right?
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah,
I use Dreamweaver,
but I used other tools
before Dreamweaver.
I used Notepad.
MATT GAUNT: Notepad's
not really a tool, is it?
ADDY OSMANI: What are
you talking about?
Notepad was the pinnacle
tool of its time.
MATT GAUNT: How is
it a pinnacle tool?
It was text.
That was it.
ADDY OSMANI: It was text.
That's all you needed.
MATT GAUNT: But it's not a tool.
It's just like, nah.
ADDY OSMANI: Notepad
didn't you let you change
the font face until Windows 98.
MATT GAUNT: And that was a
beautiful day for you, I'd say.
ADDY OSMANI: It was a
beautiful day for me.
It's like we got
one new feature.
That's a party.
MATT GAUNT: That was the
one feature everyone wanted.
Everything else, nah.
Like I used to use--
Dreamweaver was the first one
I think I used.
No, actually, it was Frontpage.
Frontpage was beautiful.
ADDY OSMANI: Frontpage?
Was this Frontpage 2.0?
MATT GAUNT: I can't
remember the version.
It was old school, though,
and I enjoyed it greatly.
I had like a
fluorescent mushroom
as my tiled background.
It was great.
ADDY OSMANI:
Frontpage was great.
You could easily add in your
marquee tags and your blink
tags.
MATT GAUNT: Dancing babies,
accounts, under constructions.
ADDY OSMANI: Fire.
Just random fire
anywhere on your page.
MATT GAUNT: So I use
Packaging Control just
for when I'm installing things.
Like I've had to install
it at some point.
But what do you--
ADDY OSMANI: So I usually
use-- so Package Control
is a lot like Tinder for
Sublime Text modules.
You swipe left or right
depending on the quality
of plug-in you're after.
MATT GAUNT: So which ones
do you swipe right for?
ADDY OSMANI: Swipe
right is good.
MATT GAUNT: Right is good.
The one that you want to keep.
Yes.
ADDY OSMANI: I'm
terrible at Tinder.
So I swipe right for linters.
I love linters.
Linters help make sure
that your code quality is
where you want it at.
MATT GAUNT: I use
Linters as well.
I've been using [? JSON ?]
for a little while.
And it's actually
been insanely good.
So if you do things
like foo.helloword,
and you haven't actually
defined foo anywhere,
that doesn't make sense.
You can't call a function
helloworld on nothing.
So for things like that,
it's super helpful.
And I used to have
[? JSON ?] in and my
build process, which
is fine, but it would
complain in the background.
And it's so much easier just
having it in my text editor
there and then.
And it just catches tons
of little errors like that.
ADDY OSMANI: That's awesome.
So you can easily
visualize where
you're breaking your code,
and you can go in and fix it.
That's pretty cool.
So on a similar to that, I
love using a tool called JSCS
for making sure that you're
following your JavaScript style
guide.
And here I've got JSCS running
against a piece of code.
And it's highlighting
anywhere where I'm
going away from my style guide.
I've got operators that are
sticking to variables that they
shouldn't be.
I've got spaces in front
of opening brackets.
One of the really
cool things about JSCS
is they recently
added this option that
lets you go and format your code
so it fixes all of the style
guide issues for you.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
You don't even have
to do anything.
ADDY OSMANI: It's amazing.
Exactly.
MATT GAUNT: So does it have like
a [? JSON ?] RCFile as well?
ADDY OSMANI: It does.
It does.
So similar to the way [? JSON ?]
has got [? a JSON ?] RCFile,
right?
MATT GAUNT: Yeah.
ADDY OSMANI: So this is
a very similar concept.
You can set a preset
that you want to use.
So JSCS supports the Google
JavaScript Style Guide.
And if you want to customize
that a little bit it,
it supports you doing that.
MATT GAUNT: So anything you
don't like from a default one--
boom.
One of the packages that
I'm finding actually
more and more useful
is ColorHighlighter.
All it does is it just shows
this like underlined color
of whatever's in the CSS.
When you hover over it, it
covers the entire background
with that bit of text with
the color that it represents.
And one of the nice
things that I realized
is under the package
settings, you
can actually just
switch it out so you
can stay filled all the time.
And then any color in your
CSS, it will always be filled.
And it's just really
handy just because you
can see a color in
your page, quickly see
where it is in the CSS, and make
any tweaks you want to make.
ADDY OSMANI: Right.
So normally people end
up using external tools
to go and select colors.
But this is really useful
because, let's say,
you're messing
around your styles,
and you just want
to change the color.
Just bring up color
picker inside Sublime,
change the color, hit pick, and
it'll go and update the value.
MATT GAUNT: This actually
swaps it in the file.
Nice.
ADDY OSMANI: Yeah, it'll
swap it right in line.
And if you happen to be
using a getter plug-in,
it'll also highlight
that with the color
that you've just chosen.
So it's nice and visual.
MATT GAUNT: So I
mean, it kind of
does what ColorHighlighter does,
but in a lesser form and more
rubbish.
Yeah, sure, OK.
ADDY OSMANI: For a
given definition.
MATT GAUNT: The
only other plug-in
that I use on a regular
basis is AutoFileName.
And all it does is, whenever
you're typing in a file,
whether it be adding it in HTML
like referencing a CSS file
or adding an image as
a background image,
as you're typing, it just
says, this is probably the file
that you're going to
type in, whether it's
a folder or a file name.
And it just autofills
it, basically.
ADDY OSMANI: You may just
be the laziest human being
I've ever met.
MATT GAUNT: No.
All it's doing is just stopping
me from adding in typos.
ADDY OSMANI: OK,
so it avoids you
having to go through the file
tree and look for the file
that you're working on.
MATT GAUNT: Exactly.
ADDY OSMANI: Do you
use Autoprefixer?
MATT GAUNT: I use it
in my build process.
ADDY OSMANI: OK, so you can
also use it in your editor.
Just work on some styles
without any prefixes,
go and enable a plugin, it'll
fill out everything for you.
MATT GAUNT: But like why
have it in your text edits?
Because the build
process makes sense.
You type your CSS.
You do all the things.
Build process picks it all
out, creates the final output,
and then it keeps
the CSS just clean.
It doesn't have any of the
stuff that you normally have.
ADDY OSMANI: I
guess this is useful
if you're working on
a smaller prototype
and you want the
same benefits as you
get in the build process.
MATT GAUNT: So basically,
when you're too
lazy to add in a build process.
ADDY OSMANI: Exactly.
Yes.
MATT GAUNT: Nice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]